did you know that there was a country
that would forcibly sterilized its own
citizens if they scored low on an IQ
test what kind of monstrous nation would
oh okay it was the United States from
the 1920s until the 1970s
yikes well at least nowadays people are
not trying to use IQ to rationalize
policies that harm people okay they
still are and that's totally immoral
even if the IQ test is a completely
comprehensive measurement of general
intelligence okay it's not alright while
there may be some value to IQ tests
they've also been used to falsely
justify hurting people based on well
racism and classism hey guys I'm Sunna
and this Sunday we're talking about how
the IQ score came to be and how well it
can be useful in some ways it's been
used in some pretty awful ways including
in so-called erased science which isn't
really a science and if you think this
is an interesting topic and want more
don't forget to click Subscribe
[Music]
so the IQ or intelligence quotient was
developed in the early 1900s and since
then most folks see it as the test to
determine how smart a person is or isn't
and this was also around the same time
that eugenics aka controlling the
population through selective breeding
was gaining popularity as a means of
protecting the future of the country
against things like quote indiscriminate
immigration criminal degenerates and
race suicide in the IQ test ended up
playing a pretty big part in the
eugenics movement in 1927 the Supreme
Court ruled on a landmark case buck vs.
Bell which legalized the forced
sterilization of more than 60,000
Americans for reasons like developmental
disabilities and low IQ scores and that
practice continued through the mid 1970s
which wasn't that long ago like when the
Brady Bunch was on the air remember
Marcia now IQ still matters today in the
u.s. scores are used to set kids on
education tracks that define the
trajectory of their entire future and
some Police Department's have a maximum
IQ limit because they say they don't
want police to get bored and quit okay
and one US president even bragged about
the IQ score that he thinks he probably
has despite the grammar mistake laid in
tweet he used to brag about it but we
won't name names so what is an IQ
exactly and how is it measured
neuroscientist Kevin Mitchell of Trinity
College Dublin in Ireland breaks that
down for us
IQ tests measure a range of different
cognitive abilities or aptitudes such as
quantitative reasoning verbal abilities
processing speed memory language and so
on and really what they find is that
people vary on each of those different
sorts of cognitive areas but underlying
that there's some general factor that
contributes to all of those and that's
where the IQ score comes from but here's
the thing
IQ tests don't measure all types of
intelligence they don't do a great job
of accounting for cultural bias and
tests they don't take into account the
highly variable environmental factors
that impact IQ scores and on top of all
of that people use IQ scores to weigh
over generalize about individuals and
populations cognitive abilities
that last point that is by far the most
nefarious one and underlies some of the
most detrimental public policies and
I'll explain why but first let's talk
about how IQ tests don't exactly measure
how generally smart a person is IQ
scores are a proxy they're an imperfect
proxy for some sort of general
intelligence for example social
intelligence is not well captured in IQ
tests and that's something that is
extremely sophisticated cognitive
processing that we're doing when we're
interacting with people trying to
understand what they feel what they
think what they know I think it's on IQ
tests don't measure things like
long-term memory kinesthetic or creative
thinking all of which are important
facets of general intelligence despite
being ignored on IQ tests in other words
IQ tests are only measuring a certain
type of general intelligence that is
decontextualized from actual general
intelligence but even general
intelligence isn't necessarily the best
indicator of what you're capable of
because you can totally kick ass in one
area that happens to be measured by an
IQ test but your overall score would be
lowered if you scored low in another
area meaning you could be a genius in
one thing but a generalized number is
keeping you back and then there's a
question of the bias and IQ testing
being baked in consciously or not along
with the values of the people who wrote
the test not every culture has the same
criteria for defining and measuring
intelligence for instance some cultures
place way more value on practical or
social thinking rather than abstract
thinking that IQ tests focus on even our
comfort levels with tests especially
written test is a product of cultural
conditioning so the IQ test is to a
certain extent a cultural background
test and context matters outside of
culture too like environmental factors
factors that can be as small as not
getting enough sleep and forgetting your
morning coffee before taking the exam
too well your socioeconomic status and
even how industrialized your country is
we'll get to that in just a second and
that's super important for the people in
the back who still think race is
genetically linked to intelligence CC
Charles Murray and Richard J Herrnstein
who are the authors of the famous book
the bell curve that makes that ignorant
I mean argument it's worth pointing out
that Murray works for a libertarian
think-tank the American Enterprise
Institute which according to fair is
against multiculturalism bilingual
education
and affirmative action Murray also went
on The Colbert Report where they had
this exchange you also took a little bit
of heat because in in the bell curve you
cited researchers and research that was
funded by white supremacists and Nazi
groups oh come on
no no evidence I know I know I know what
you're referring to but Stephen yeah you
had 17 researchers you cited
contributors to the racist journal
mankind quarterly and 13 scholars cited
who were grant recipients from the
Pioneer fund which was established and
run by Nazi sympathizers eugenicist and
white supremacist Stephen I can't tell
you how hard it is after 17 years to see
this nonsense brought up again well I I
think it's refreshing that following
this book you're writing a book that
contains no black people in it
whatsoever and it's also received
funding linked to the right-wing
billionaire Koch brothers and Murray's
work has also been credited as
foundational for the welfare reform Act
of 1996 that removed an economic safety
net for millions of Americans till this
day and he's the same guy who the
Southern Poverty Law Center lists today
as a white nationalist and who said it's
genetics that caused poverty yeah he
actually did say that in the National
Review in 2000 here's the quote
scrolling over my face please read this
this guy help take away welfare ok but
Murray has the cause and effect reversed
studies have found that exposure to
poverty leads to a significant IQ drop
and so taking away welfare creates this
vicious cycle people are pushed into
poverty because of factors outside their
control like the legacy of institutional
racism but then they are kept there in
part because poverty has an impact on
their cognitive ability the people who
are pushed into poverty in the first
place tend to be black and Latino
communities in this country because
again institutional racism and then
people like charles murray blame
genetics AKA racial differences on low
IQ while ignoring the findings that IQ
can be lowered by circumstances like
poverty the idea that we should expect
there to be intelligence differences
between these large continental racial
groupings again is really wild
speculation for that to happen
what you would have to have is very
strong consistent and sustained
directional selective pressure and what
that means is that groups in in one area
would because of their environment have
to have been exposed to strong selective
pressure to push intelligence one way or
another meaning environments across
entire continents would have to be the
same somehow to make the continents
entire population evolve different
intelligences from the entire population
of other entire continents which would
also need to have a single environment
and maybe you're thinking skin color
evolved differently on different
continents so why not intelligence well
because brains don't work that way skin
color is an interesting one because it
has evolved multiple times from
light-skinned to dark-skinned back to
light skin back to dark skin and so on
but it's a much much simpler trait
genetically speaking advanced something
like intelligence which involves
thousands and thousands of genetic
variants variants basically brains can't
evolve as easily as changing a small
handful of genes like with skin or hair
color because brains are made up of so
many different genes so saying you think
different races could have different
innate intelligence levels may be like
saying you think different races have
different amounts of fingers and going
back to environmental factors even
identical twins who are genetic clones
have shown up to a 29-point IQ gap when
raised in different social classes with
different education levels the average
IQ scores have risen over the past
century or so consistently in every
country where IQ tests have been done
and actually out of at a more rapid rate
in developing countries than in
developed ones and that is attributable
people think to increase nutrition to
better health care both maternal health
care and infant health care more
education and also probably
industrialization urbanization Mitchell
uses the example of Ireland Scotland and
England to show how much of a role
environmental factors play in measuring
IQ more than genetics the 70s and 80s
the average IQ scores in Ireland and
Scotland were significantly lower than
in the neighboring country of England
that has completely shifted over the
years as there's been increasing
urbanization increased move to cities
increased industrialization a change
from agricultural practice
so that the populace really has become
more prone to these habits of abstract
thought education has increased also
nutrition and health care of increase
and so the IQ scores now in Ireland and
Scotland are on a par with those in
England and that really shows that
cultural factors can have a huge impact
on average IQ scores so the average IQ
scores between Ireland and England were
not due to genetic differences they
weren't an immutable biological fact
they were just due to cultural
differences which have gone away over
time another example are the average IQ
scores among Kenyan children which rose
over 26 points between 1984 and 1998 and
not because they evolved impossibly fast
in half a generation it's because there
were massive improvements in health
nutrition and parental literacy IQ is in
many cases more a measure of
socio-economic class than it is a
measure of innate intelligence IQ and
wealth are correlated with each other
now that may be because more intelligent
people do better in the economy and
therefore have higher wealth but it's
also probably true that people in more
wealthy areas more wealthy families have
more access to education more habits of
valuing education that advantage may be
amplified over time because of the
experiences that they have so you get us
sort of in that case of a virtuous
circle which amplifies intelligence but
at the you know and on the flipside and
in areas where education is not well
funded then that can lead to a vicious
circle that just cements those sort of
social inequalities so there you have it
the measurement of IQ is sometimes more
useful as a tool for some pretty heinous
political goals than it is as a
measurement of your actual intelligence
and mental ability so I like them apples
so one of the craziest things that I
learned in the course of like
researching this video was finding out
that California in particular is
sterilized 20,000 people leading the
nation in eugenics let us know what you
guys think in the comments and don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
come back next Sunday when we come at
you with another great video